as humans we have a lot of senses that
we put to use on a regular basis they
include sight smell taste touch and
hearing but have you ever wondered how
it all works
how do you look at a beautiful painting
in an art museum or smell the rain
outside on a stormy day or feel that
your favorite pair of socks are still a
little damp and need another cycle in
the dryer
how does that information make its way
from our sensory organs to our brains
well the answer lies in the nervous
system
if you remember our bodies are made up
of multiple complex organ systems that
work together to perform all different
kinds of functions
today let's talk specifically about the
nervous system which is an organ system
that allows us to sense and respond to
our environment
to begin the nervous system contains
specialized cells and cell parts called
sensory receptors which are able to pick
up signals from the environment these
signals are called stimuli or stimulus
if you're talking about just one
stimuli can come in many different forms
for instance mechanical stimuli are
physical in nature and are involved with
our senses of touch and hearing you can
strum a guitar feeling the strings
against your fingertips and listening to
the unique tones it produces as the
strings vibrate those are all mechanical
stimuli chemical stimuli are made up of
molecules and are involved with their
senses of smell and taste to illustrate
an example imagine eating a tasty bowl
of chicken noodle soup as you spoon
mouthfuls of soup into your mouth your
taste and olfactory receptors are
flooded with molecules that signal the
qualities of the food you're eating
these molecular signals are chemical
stimuli and in this case the molecules
from the chicken noodle soup convey that
the food you're eating is savory and
extremely delicious
lastly electromagnetic stimuli are
involved with our sense of sight and
include the light that comes into our
eyes every day the sunlight that makes
you squint the traffic lights you see on
the street and the vibrant and diverse
colors all around you these are just a
few examples of electromagnetic stimuli
in the form of light so then what
happens after sensory receptors detect
stimuli well once a sensory receptor
receives the information it passes this
information along nerve cells
here's a picture of a nerve cell which
is specialized to transmit information
in the form of electrical signals these
signals are transmitted along nerves to
the brain which is then responsible for
processing or organizing sensory
information from different sensory
receptors
after processing the information the
brain can elicit a response and also
store the information in the form of a
memory for future use
for example imagine you're playing catch
with friends in a park your sensory
receptors pick up information as you
watch the ball come towards you and feel
the wind on your skin
signals from these receptors travel
along nerve cells to your brain where
all these different signals are
organized
then your brain elicits a response such
as moving to just the right spot and
putting your hands out to catch the ball
and the brain also stores a memory
perhaps remembering playing catch as a
fun activity that you'd want to do again
you can almost think of this flow of
information from a stimulus to sensing
to processing and finally to eliciting a
response or storing information like a
complex relay race
sensory receptors pick up the message in
the form of stimuli and pass this
information along to nerves and to the
brain
only in this relay the end result at the
finish line is a response to the
stimulus and information storage so to
summarize today we talked about how our
bodies sense and respond to the
environment information is transferred
from a stimulus to a sensory receptor to
nerve cells and finally to the brain
where processing occurs whether we're
aware of it or not our nervous system is
working at rapid fire speed every day to
provide us with the information our
bodies need to sense what's in our
environment and thrive in it